.
DON'T WORRY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
ARE OVER, BUT THE BALANCE ON
CAPITOL HILL IS STILL IN FLUX,
AS WE PREDICTED REPEATEDLY ON
THIS SHOW, KEY RACES WERE
DECIDED BY RAZOR THIN MARGINS,
MANY ELECTIONS YET TO BE CALLED.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE.
WE KNEW IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
TIGHT.
WE WARNED ALL OF YOU EVERY
NIGHT, IN FACT, ON ELECTION EVE,
WE POINTED OUT, THE RAZOR THIN
MARGINS THAT DECIDED 2016 AND
2020, AND WE MADE THIS
PREDICTION.
JUST TO REMIND YOU --
>> AS A REMINDER, THREE KEY
SWING STATES, IF YOU GO BACK TO
2016, PROPELLED DONALD TRUMP TO
VICTORY IN 2016.
THE COMBINED VOTE OF THOSE THREE
SWING STATES, 70,000 VOTES.
2020, 43,000 VOTES IN THREE
STATES.
THAT WOULD BE GEORGIA,
WISCONSIN, AND ARIZONA DECIDED
THE ELECTION.
IF YOU STAY HOME, DEMOCRATS,
WELL, THEY'RE LIKELY TO WIN.
YOU WILL GET THE GOVERNMENT YOU
DESERVE.
WE ARE WARNING YOU, WE WARNED
YOU.
I CAN'T SAY FOR SURE WHETHER
RUMORS OF THE RED TSUNAMI
STARTED, BECAUSE POLLS IN ALMOST
EVERY KEY RACE WERE WITHIN THE
MARGIN OF ERROR, MOSTLY ONLY ONE
OR TWO POINTS.
THE GLOWING PREDICTIONS OF A BIG
RED WAVE WERE FRANKLY FOOLISH.
I HAVE A RULE IN LIFE, NEVER
OVERPROMISE AND UNDERDELIVER.
YOU WANT TO UNDERPROMISE AND
OVERDELIVER.
THIS IS A DEEPLY DIVIDED
COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WILL VOTE FOR A
DEMOCRAT JUST SO THEY HAVE A
RUBBER STAMP.
AS LONG AS THEY HAVE A PULSE,
WHERE, BY THE WAY, TURNOUT
MATTERS AND EVERY SINGLE VOTE IS
CRITICAL.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE GOOD NEWS
TONIGHT.
YOU HEARD SOME OF IT WITH KARI
LAKE.
THE FIRST NEVADA, WHERE ADAM
LAXALT LOOKS LIKE THE FAVORITE
TO WIN THE SENATE SEAT IN
NEVADA.
KARI LAKE IS THE HEAVY FAVORITE
TO WIN THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IN
THE STATE OF ARIZONA WHERE NEW
VOTE TOTALS ARE COMING IN AS WE
SPEAK.
THE RACE FOR THE SENATE IN
ARIZONA IS VERY REAL TONIGHT.
BLAKE MASTERS DOES IN FACT HAVE
A SOLID PATH TO CATCH MARK
KELLY.
IT'S CLOSE, BUT IT'S REAL.
I'LL EXPLAIN IN DETAIL IN A
MINUTE.
FIRST HERE'S WHERE WE STAND AT
THIS HOUR.
REPUBLICAN TED BUDD RAN A GREAT
RACE.
BIG WIN.
J.D. VANCE WON IN THE STATE OF
OHIO.
IT WAS A HUGE NIGHT FOR ALMOST
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN FLORIDA.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A
MOMENT.
ON THE GUBERNATORIAL LEVEL, BOTH
STACEY ABRAMS AND BETO "BOSE
ZOE" O'ROURKE, OVERWHELMING
REJECTED BY VOTERS AGAIN DESPITE
A FORTUNE BEING SPENT ON BOTH
RACES.
HERE'S THE SCARY PART.
THIS YEAR DEMOCRATS NOMINATED
THOSE THREE PEOPLE, THE MOST
EXTREME CANDIDATES IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
IN WISCONSIN, ANTI-LAW AND ORDER
SOCIALIST MANDELA BARNES LOST BY
ONLY ONE POINT TO INCUMBENT
SENATOR RON JOHNSON.
IN GEORGIA, RADICAL RAPHAEL
WARNOCK JUST FORCED A RUNOFF
WITH HERSCHEL WALKER.
WARNOCK, YOU KNOW, THE GUY THAT
REFERRED TO POLICE AS GANGSTERS
AND THUGS AND OF COURSE WANTS TO
DEFUND THE POLICE, DEMANDING
THAT AMERICA REPENT FOR ITS
WHITENESS, PRAISING THE LIKES OF
FIDEL CASTRO, THE REVEREND
JEREMIAH WRIGHT AND ANTI-SEMITE
LOUIS FARRAKHAN, ACCUSED OF
RUNNING OVER HIS ESTRANGED WIFE
WITH A CAR AFTER A DOMESTIC
DISPUTE AND RUNNING A CAMP THAT
ABUSED KIDS, AND ARRESTED FOR
THAT, AND NEARLY 2 MILLION
GEORGIANS VOTED FOR THIS GUY?
IN PENNSYLVANIA, FREEDOM FOR
FIRST AND SECOND-DEGREE
MURDERERS, RAPISTS, LEGALIZE
DRUG, WANTS TO SET UP SAFE
HEROIN INJECTION SITES FOR
ADDICTS, AND IN THE SPRING
FETTERMAN SUFFERED A MASSIVE
STROKE.
DIDN'T EVEN CAMPAIGN BEFORE
500,000, NEARLY 600,000 VOTES
WERE CAST.
HE DELIVERED THE SINGLE WORST
DEBATE PERFORMANCE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
HE GOT 2.6 MILLION VOTES.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE'S A RUBBER STAMP FOR
BIDEN.
DOUG MASTRIANO LOST BY 13
POINTS, OZ LOST BY OVER TWO
POINTS, GETTING DOUBLE-DIGIT
SPLIT TICKETS LIKE THIS.
BY THE WAY, IT'S ALMOST UNHEARD
OF.
ALSO THE MEDIA NEVER ASKED
FETTERMAN THE TOUGH QUESTIONS.
THEY WERE COMPLICIT AS ALWAYS.
ULTIMATELY ALL THREE STATES,
WISCONSIN, GEORGIA,
PENNSYLVANIA, ARE GETTING HARDER
AND HARDER FOR REPUBLICANS TO
WIN.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS AT PLAY
HERE NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT.
ONE, DEMOCRATS ARE VOTING BLUE
NO MATTER WHO.
JUST LIKE THEY DID IN 2020 WITH
JOE BIDEN.
I THINK THEY WOULD VOTE FOR A
CORPS AS LONG AS IT WAS A
RELIABLE DEMOCRATIC VOTE.
IN OTHER WORDS, A NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALIST RUBBER STAMP.
WHATEVER JOE SAYS, WHATEVER
CHUCKY SAYS, THEY WILL DO.
NUMBER TWO, THERE IS, AND
ESPECIALLY ACCELERATED BECAUSE
OF COVID, AND OF COURSE THE BABY
BOOMERS ARE NOW RETIRING,
THERE'S BEEN AN ACCELERATED
MIGRATION NOW GOING ON AROUND
THE COUNTRY, NOT MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT, YOU
HAVE PEOPLE RETIRING, PEOPLE
WANTING TO GET AWAY FROM HIGH
TAXES, THEY WANT GOOD WEATHER, A
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE, BABY
BOOMERS RETIRING, OTHER
AMERICANS RETIRING.
THEY'RE MOVING FROM STATES LIKE
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, ILLINOIS, TO
STATES LIKE TEXAS, THE
CAROLINAS, TENNESSEE, AND
ESPECIALLY FLORIDA.
LOOK AT THIS.
ACCORDING TO THE U.S. CENSUS,
FROM 2010 TO 2020, ROUGHLY
274,000 PEOPLE MOVED TO THE
SUNSHINE STATE, THE FREE STATE
OF FLORIDA A, EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
UNDER RON DESANTIS THAT NUMBER
HAS ONLY GROWN, PEAKING AT 850
NEW RESIDENTS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
850 NEW PEOPLE MOVING DOWN TO
FLORIDA EVERY DAY.
A DECADE AGO, LEE ZELDIN, WHO
RAN A TERRIFIC CAMPAIGN,
PROBABLY BOO HAVE CARRIED NEW
YORK, IF NOT FOR ALL THE NEW
YORK REPUBLICANS, THAT WERE
SMART, LEFT NEW YORK, FOR THE NO
INCOME TAX STATE OF FLORIDA.
CLEARLY THE NEW RESIDENTS ARE
HAPPY TO CALL FLORIDA THEIR
HOME.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS AND SENATOR
RUBIO, ELECTED OFFICIALS, JOIN
US IN A MOMENT, RE-ELECTED BY
NEARLY 20 POINTS.
THEY'VE DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB.
FLORIDA IS NO LONGER A SWING
STATE.
BY THE WAY, FLORIDA'S ELECTION
PROTOCOLS SHOULD BE A MODEL FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AS RUBIO
TWEETED, QUOTE, IF FLORIDA CAN
COUNT 5.7 MILLION BALLOTS IN
HOURS, HOW CAN IT TAKES DAYS FOR
STATES TO COUNT LESS THAN
2 MILLION VOTES?
GREAT QUESTION.
WE'LL ASK THE SENATOR IN A
SECOND.
IN THAT CASE, AT THIS HOUR, ALL
EYES ARE OUT WEST.
THIS ELECTION IS FAR FROM OVER,
WHERE THE VOTE COUNTING REMAINS
PAINFULLY SLOW, AND IT'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
WE MAY NOT KNOW THE RESULTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN ELECTION FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
IN NEVADA, THE VOTE TOTAL HAS
BEEN HOVERING AROUND 74% FOR
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS ON
END, BUT REPUBLICANS SENATE
CANDIDATE ADAM LAXALT REMAINS IN
THE LEAD, AND BASED ON THE
REMAINING VOTE HE'S IN A VERY,
VERY GOOD POSITION TO WIN THIS
RACE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, MOMENTS
AGO, LAXALT TWEETED, QUOTE, OF
THE 84,000 VOTES LEFT TO COUNT
IN CLARK COUNTY, CORTEZ MASTO
COULD WIN 63% OF THEM AND STILL
LOSE.
THAT DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE GAINS WE WILL MAKE FROM
RURAL COUNTIES.
GREAT NEWS FOR REPUBLICANS AT
THIS HOUR TONIGHT.
WE GO TO THE STATE OF ARIZONA.
THE COUNTING WILL LIKELY GO ON
FOR DAYS, AN EMBARRASSMENT,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, THEY COUNTED
THE -- REMEMBER IN IRAQ THEY HAD
THE VOTE THAT WENT FORWARD, AND
EVERYBODY WAS POINTING UP THAT
PURPLE FINGER?
I THINK THAT VOTING WENT FAST
EVER THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
ARIZONA AND NEVADA.
AS OF THIS AFTERNOON, GET THIS,
MARICOPA COUNTY ANNOUNCED THEY
STILL HAD OVER 400,000-PLUS
BALLOTS TO BE COUNTED.
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME.
WE GO BACK TO MACARONI AND MARCS
TWEET, HOW DID THEY DO,
7.5 MILLION, AND THIS IS THE
MESS THAT IS ARIZONA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'VE GOT OVER -- WE DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT NUMBERS, BUT OVER
400,000 VOTES YET TO BE COUNTED
AND REPORTED.
THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE.
THOSE ARE MAINLY, AS STEVEN
MENTIONED, THESE ARE MAINLY THE
EARLY VOTES THAT HAVE BEEN
DROPPED OFF SINCE FRIDAY,
INCLUDING YESTERDAY'S VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF AT LEAST 275,000.
SO AGAIN THAT PROCESS IS GOING
TO GO ON ON THE RECORDER'S SIDE
OF THE HOUSE.
WHEN THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THAT
FULL VERIFICATION PROCESS, THEN
THEY WILL BE TURNED OVER HERE TO
BE TABULATED.
>> Sean: NEVER MIND THE
TABULATORS WORKING.
ANYWAY, HOW DOES THIS INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE?
HOW IS THIS FAIR TO THE PEOPLE
OF ARIZONA, THE PEOPLE IN THE 47
OTHER STATES THAT DESERVE TO
KNOW THE OUTCOME OF THIS
ELECTION?
THEY HAVE 275,000 -- NOW, THIS
IS THE INTERESTING PART OF -- OF
THESE VOTES WERE HAND-DELIVERED
ON ELECTION DAY.
SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEIR VOTE IS BEING
COUNTED.
MAYBE PEOPLE THAT DON'T TRUST
THE SYSTEM.
ANOTHER 175,000 HAND-DELIVERED
THE WEEKEND BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
PEOPLE REALLY WANTING THEIR
VOTES TO BE COUNTED.
THEN YOU'VE GOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS MORE VOTES IN RURAL
COUNTIES THAT WOULD GREATLY FIT
THE PROFILE OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS
THAT WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR VOTE WAS COUNTED.
KEEP IN MIND, ARIZONA IS
INCOMPETENT.
COWARDLY SECRETARY OF STATE
KATIE HOBBS, WHO SHOULD HAVE
RECUSED HERSELF IS OVERSEEING
THIS ELECTION, HOPING TO BE
PROMOTED TO GOVERNOR.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HOBBS, WE
BELIEVE, THE OUTSTANDING VOTE IN
ARIZONA IS VERY FAVORABLE TO
REPUBLICANS WHEN ALL THE VOTES
ARE COUNTED.
KARI LAKE IS THE ODDS-ON
FAVORITE TO WIN BIG.
IN THE SENATE, REPUBLICAN BLAKE
MASTERS, HE ABSOLUTELY HAS A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO WIN HIS RACE
AS WELL.
WE'RE WATCHING IT CLOSELY.
WE CAN'T TELL YOU THE OUTCOME AT
THIS POINT.
NOW WHAT HAPPENS IN ARIZONA AND
NEVADA COULD DECIDE THE BALANCE
OF POWER IN THE U.S. SENATE.
LOOK WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE HOUSE,
WHERE REPUBLICANS WILL LIKELY
WIN THE MAJORITY.
AGAIN, COUNTING HAS BEEN TOO
SLOW, ANOTHER NATIONAL DISGRACE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IT COMES WITH THE ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE AND ISSUE SUBPOENAS
AND ALONG WITH THE POWER OF THE
PURSE REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE THAT
POWER IN THE HOUSE AND NOW
LIKELY EVEN IN THE SENATE.
NOW JOE BIDEN IS NOW SUDDENLY
WILLING TO MEET WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY AND OTHER REPUBLICAN
LEADERS.
HE SAYS THAT THEY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO WORK WITH HIM, TO
UNITE THE COUNTRY.
BUT IN THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS,
HE WAS SMEARING AND SLANDERING
AND BESMIRCHING, USING EVERY BIT
OF CHARACTER ASSASSINATION AND
LIE THAT HE COULD, ATTACKING
THEM.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY WANT TO SIT
WITH THIS GUY?
>> THEY'VE BEEN EMBOLDENED
VIOLENCE AGAINST ELECTION
OFFICIALS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE MORE
THAN 300 ELECTION DENIERS ON THE
BALLOT ALL ACROSS AMERICA THIS
YEAR.
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE IMPACT THIS
IS HAVING ON OUR COUNTRY.
PITS DAMAGING.
IT'S CORROSIVE.
IT'S DESTRUCTIVE.
>> COMPARED TO THE MAGA -- MEGA
MAGA I CALL THEM, TRICKLE DOWN
ECONOMICS OF THE REPUBLICANS
THESE DAYS, FOLKS, THIS AIN'T
YOUR FATHER'S REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THESE ARE DIFFERENT CATS.
JUST LOOK AT THE FACTS.
YOU'RE RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS ON THE
BALLOT.
YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE IS ON THE
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE ON
THE BALLOT.
SOMETHING ELSE ON THE BALLOT.
CHARACTER.
CHARACTER IS ON THE BALLOT.
>> Sean: A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
CAT.
COME ON, MAN, THAT'S A BUNCH OF
MALARKEY.
ANYWAY, REPUBLICANS MUST REJECT
THIS PARTISANSHIP, INVESTIGATE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, BLOCK
JOE'S PROPOSALS, THAT WILL
HAPPEN, AND WE CAN BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF GETTING THE COUNT